[Applaudissements]
série 6r qui travaille également pour j
+ sur canal + wii les shérifs sa vraie
émission va continuer l'année prochaine
je l'espère aussi bien très bonne
émission sur le foot très bonne émission
merci beaucoup alors vous savez que je
scrute les missions et que je vois vos
moindres faits et gestes
il me permet notamment de voir qui parmi
vous est au dessus du lot alors sur vous
et la meilleure émission à la bière la
meilleure mi juillet je pense que c'est
c is a été bien hier dans l'attitude
donc jean-michel doc gynéco très fort
hier près du bord alors vous un indice
il est leader tnt mais mais mais c'est
sûr qu'il n'est pas leader à langue
française regardez moi ça à huy
[Musique]
alors oui il faire une faute de français
ça peut arriver à tout le monde ça rame
faire au moins trois ou quatre et demi
de plus voilà qui m'a insulté moi mais
mes fans français international alors
oui faire deux fautes de français en
trois minutes ça peut arriver à tout le
monde
justin bieber avait arrêté ça ça son
concert à l'esat tourner un petit peu
internationale avant la fin c'est à dire
que est comme moi ils donnent beaucoup
comme lui je donne beaucoup et parfois
le rythme c'est effrayant mais faire
trois fois dauphin servent une émission
ça n'arrive que sur w9 ou nrj 12 je
voulais vérifier sur le carnet des
otages et demandé pourquoi m de lambeaux
et celui qui a fait à b1 et sort hier
[Applaudissements]
qui sait vous pardonner chez vous amat a
d'autres qualités que l'on enfoncé c'est
pas grave je vais te dire toi tu es bien
meilleure à l'écrit par année c'est vrai
alors anne c'est pas ton truc à bon
compte et amateurs c'est vrai j'ai
l'impression c'est pas mon truc leaders
tiennent voilà tu as dit un vieux dîner
à la maison ma fille tu vas voir si
c'est pas mon truc je me rends chez moi
je ne mange pas chez les autres
or qu'est ce qu'elle a dit non non non
non non je n'aime pas me comparer aux 10
gbe la peine dylan a dit lady laura non
il faut dire dans vos dîners aux
hespérides vont devenir ma chérie d'un
tir des poignets à l'essor sur la route
vers la balle tu as tous traumatisés
on est dans la m faisait quoi avec
bottes et avec votre chemise aller
chercher des pommes de terre de la voie
d'allah obtenait rend les rangs de niro
mais elle a mis tellement de temps à
sortir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une demi heure la mer sérieux et quand
elles gagnent sur son tabouret fleurs on
dirait qu'elle craint playboy salaire
jamais la pub assurent leur vient pas
aller sur la famille mais je les adore
faire danser quand le canard et avec ça
la pluie hier soir à 20h35 la france
entière s'est arrêtée puisque toute la
population s'est mise sur ses 8 pour
découvrir là la nouvelle coiffure du
prince du paf
finalement tout le monde a regardé avec
ce joli mélange de couleurs comme une
glace un peu vanille ou au chocolat en
bas un c est encore t'as pas tout vu
quand vous êtes un créateur de nouvelles
tendances nombre beaucoup de stars ont
immédiatement demandé à leur coiffeur ce
qu'on appelle désormais dans les salons
de visages issic la coupe d'art cas
c'est le premier c'est stéphane bern
regarder si michel drucker
ça lui va bien
les plus grands scientifiques du monde
non ils sont mieux lui connaissons mieux
comme ça maintenant niveau coiffure on
peut pas dire que ce soit leur point
fort
non mais c'est vrai voilà bah on les
adore ils ont très beau visage mais
aussi avec la coiffure ma mère est très
beau très beau visage singulier mais la
voiture voilà n'est pas le voile assez
falloir t'y corps mais il tente des
choses je les beaux yeux
ils ont des très beaux yeux l'époque
d'ailleurs c'est vrai quand on les voit
à qui parler vous d'ailleurs vos yeux
c'est encore un petit sans rature non
tissé sa part à ce qui se dit
la regarder ce que voisin gaza ni doute
l'émission quand même faut pas mettre
badara 4 à vis de lui toutes les
missions et quoique ça mais ça vous
plaît l'émission j'aime beaucoup
merci qu'elle voit bien d'ailleurs à ses
yeux mon accord c'est dur pour moi mais
ils sont pas posés de son verbe son
verre ils ont fermé bien sûr bah oui moi
aussi je peux dire que j'ai des yeux
bleu canard
ils sont verts connard quoi vos yeux ils
sont quoi ils seront ouverts mais oui on
les voit ce qu'il a dit mais qu'est ce
qu'il est ce que j'aime pas dénoncer
mais j'aime bien le faire voilà
peut-être la colère ou quoi alors avec
votre déco neuf c'est ce que je fais moi
je ne dis rien je regarde dans les yeux
et je continue mon chemin
ban avait traité de connard non mais
j'ai renvoyé en fait vous avez raison
justement il ya parmi les chroniqueurs
une star de la télévision quelqu'un qui
a autant d'expérience sont élégants
mariage c'est bien sûr dont berrahma cas
c'est vrai faut pas oublier c'est une
star énormes stars et moi non mais
cérémonie de ces rémois quoi parce que
lui ne le voit pas mais je veux dire ça
regardez maintenant on va vous ouvrir
les yeux sur votre carrière
à propos de mariage à quelques jours
cyril hanouna a balancé une histoire
très personnelle sur ans sur vous
benjamin et vous étiez tellement choqué
que j'oublie de lancer tout de suite un
zoo de nouveau une caste a assez
extraordinaire
j'ai tatouer le prénom de ma femme sur
l'avant-bras ouais mais là tatouer le
prénom de sa femme sur la bombe alors
qu'il était encore avec son look femme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il m'a fait c'est quand la
boîte à pots cassés après abbaoui pas
vous avez un truc ça revient à un très
bien son nom ah oui c'est quoi le bail
ah bah je vous dis à tout à l'heure mais
très vite comme ça pendant non non non
ça concerne votre cul cul encore
d'accord le caca dans le cul cul et pas
que non voilà eu quelques tartes une
lettre dans toi je n'avais reçu de colis
j'ai tous refusés alors pour me voir
l'animal se moque souvent debout
benjamin castaldi mais depuis quelque
temps on découvre un nouveau cast a fini
bungie soumis maintenant c'est le benji
récalcitrants à la basse et le laurier
du nouveau casta qui veut péter la
gueule de son patron fait l'histoire des
arts martiaux il ya eu bruce lee jean
claude van damme et benjamin castaldi
vous quand vous battre contre eux parce
qu'on appelle un look et alors rien ay
tique quand tu es dans ta face oui j'ai
pas peur moi tu veux vraiment à aller
vas-y dans une cage c'est fait c'est
fait
[Applaudissements]
si vous recrutez se voir si vous avez
beaucoup de chance beaucoup de chance
qui n'est pas de répartie attentif à vos
jeux seront chemise est franchement je
dois vous le dire
c'est horrible avec tout ça va faire des
pizzas pâtes à pizza new look qui va en
parler avec moi vu fermer va faire
descalzos n'doye a mis au moins trois
fois la meilleure technique utilisation
intensive belle son manga hockey non tu
avais c'est ton slip touchant
au diable ok
[Musique]
j'adore je la donne
[Applaudissements]
je sais qu'ils s'entraînent tous les
jours je vous le dis il tient en
prennent tous les jours il va à la salle
il excelle et non non non bonjour il
s'entraîne tous les jours pour ce combat
vraiment b 10e c'est que la faune je
sais que tu t'entraînes aujourd'hui
ouais ce matin où sarah quoi j'ai fais
taper dans le sac d'accord et vous
serrez les visionner des besoins il n'a
pas peur c'est plutôt sera ça va durer 2
minutes et la pathétique qui va tomber
terminé jir l'oreille mais attachée dans
le dos que ce soit
franchement je vous dis sur trend grave
et il commence à me faire peur bon il me
fait peur comme toi s'il m'appelle un
jour être très tard le soir
non franchement ça va tu sais que tu
progresses ou pas et très humide sans
que tu progresses toi même si c'est une
mine surtout benjamin non il a de la
force mais il n'a pas tout mini ça va on
a déjà pris on a déjà fait on en a déjà
fait beaucoup déjà démunies combat et
benjamin on va le laisser s'entraîna
gens travaillent s'ils s'en souvient
encore c'est un grand moment
ce soir je vais réaliser un rêve de
beaucoup de monde bref beaucoup de
jeunes nous allons pénétrer cyril
hanouna
alors du calme du calme mathieu direct
c'est le et non non je suis ça je me
vois plus nous allons pénétrer son
cerveau c'est pas la même chose attend
des moments d'avoir des caisses qui
l'adour est ce qu'il a dit ils savent
aller vite il est vide ces attaques
bbbb sur supprimer même maison a laissé
sa part à l'épargné de vinci ou
s'inquiéter pas on sait qu'on va se voir
ce week-end était donc on le verra pas
là ni vous allez voir des moments de
l'émission où cyril interviewe des
invités je vais vous traduire ce qu'ils
pensaient vraiment à ce moment-là panda
être la petite voix dans sa tête que
vous allez entendre atteindre entre on
se suit dans le cerveau de l'animal avec
hanoune inside man tu vas chanter bien
sûr de chanter quoi donner des villes
il a rivalisé mais l envie d'aimer les
cool aussi puis je kiffe sur youtube la
halle envie d'aimer pourquoi écrivez
telle des pièces aussi spirituelle mais
parfois aussi cruel qui était vraiment
sacha guitry
mais comme mon balech je suis très bien
me dit rien écrit le rouge et le noir
avec jeunesse puis le gars il faut
qu'ils changent de nom s'appelle barbier
il a même pas de bar
ou parce que voilà c'est bon enfin on
avait un bon moment pour la france et
c'est une vidéo qui est devenu très
viral mais ils sont foutus de ma gueule
la production s'est pas bilal hassan
issa c'est agathe au cou avec la période
du début 2010 on dira quoi bomber avec
de sa symphonie j'adore sacha guitry
j'ai lu j'ai dieu juge acheter tous ces
listes bien sûr on reviendra quelquefois
je dresse que j'adore bon c'est très
très très réussie c'est gentil alain a
tous vu qu isabelle morini bosc était
une passionnée de dicter il ya quelques
jours
ouais qu elles veulent se retrouver
entièrement chocolatées mme isabelle a
également une passion que des coins où
le monde connaît sait faire des blagues
voilà souvent à base de jeux de mots
pleins d'esprit entre sauts de raymond
devos et roland magdane
c'est sur le plateau ça me fait pas rire
moi ça m'éclate voici la suite de grand
mère c'est faire un bon café mais pas
des bonnes bases
on adore ce c'est faire un bon café mais
pas des bonnes bonnes à une soirée bien
voir son papa et lui dieu sait quoi
l'espoir que la petite graine est le
monsieur lui dit pas c'est quand on met
dans maman le papa mais les petites
graines et le gamin lui dit devant 15
personnes alors qu'est ce qu'il fait
avec 7 buts après les choses n ont
jamais le dire faut gérer le dire qui va
à la chasse perd sa place
c'est pas mon neveu c'est quoi jeudi les
garçons naissent dans les choux et les
gars sont dans les choux et fille se
finisse dans les choux c'est génial et
morue des sardines pour le roi de la
mise en boîte c'est génial
non c'est très très grave la laine j'ai
vendu à la con préfère la levrette
pardon
commercer faire un bon café mais farid
ben merci j'avais averti
[Applaudissements]